your time's up you dumb [ __ ] well that's
just lazy writing hey everybody so we
finally got confirmation on some of the
new characters that are appearing in
Deadpool and it really does look like
this group here on the back of the plane
is the proto version of x-force Rob
Liefeld kind of came out and confirmed
this while I was making this video
because somebody was like is this gonna
be six pack or is it gonna be x-force he
said one word
Liefeld which means x-force and then he
retweeted someones reply of an x-force
comic book so it's like okay yeah very
definitely this is gonna be x-force or
at least the surviving members of this
team will be X force along with Colossus
negasonic and cable but there's actually
eight characters if you include cable
colossus and negasonic and technically
cable was a part of six pack in the
comics and I think for the most part
when the movie picks up cable will be a
loner working by himself but that's part
of the beauty of Deadpool usually when
they brush over a lot of comic book
history they make a lot of jokes about
it so the biggest confirmation that we
got like the actor that plays Colossus
actually did an interview so he was
talking about the characters that are
standing here the person standing behind
Deadpool is confirmed to be Shatter star
who has one of the most complicated
backstories ever he basically is a total
badass with a regenerative healing
factor who's just really good with
blades so it sounds a lot like deadpool
himself but he was one of the founding
members of x-force so one strike for
exports forming during this team next to
him in the background you see zeitgeist
has that yellow mouth covering now he
didn't debut till later in the comics
but he's also an x-force character he
basically spits gelatinous goo out of
his mouth that can eat through anything
just imagine Deadpool making fun of
people's really gross powers so remember
that Terry Crews people are kind of torn
on who his character is I know a lot of
people wanted him to be George
Washington Bridge because he also showed
up in the original x-force comic book he
was a former teammate of cable in
sixpack which predated the formation of
x-force even though in the comics it was
sort of like a retcon like x-force
happened in the early 90s then in a
later issue of x4
we learned the cable used to belong to
an old group called six-pack so even
though it predates the formation of
x-force it didn't debut till much much
later in the comics but remember one of
the things the Deadpool is best at
making fun of superhero movies in
general so Terry Crews is an amazing
comedian but he's a total badass
so he's perfect for a Deadpool movie but
think about it this way what is the
other big thing that he's been doing
recently that people know him for sorry
so he's been doing all those crazy
deodorant ads he makes a lot of jokes
about sweating there's actually an x-men
x-force character whose power is
secreting acidic sweat think about how
funny that would be and how much
Deadpool would make fun of that his name
in the comics is anarchist I don't know
if they would use that in the movie or
they would just call him by his given
name TG Alec R but he's like 6-3 so he's
a pretty huge black dude which feels
like Terry Crews could just do an
amazing job with and given the fact that
he has acidic sweat and he's the Old
Spice guy in real life just feels like
it's too right for meta comedies so
that's why I do think that he's playing
anarchist in that character also debuted
in the very same x-force issue number
116 as the zeitgeist character that we
just talked about so you have two
characters here standing on this plane
that debuted in the same issue of
x-force that have kind of similar powers
but not really like acidic sweat and
acidic spit slightly different that
probably changed it a little bit for the
movie you all know who Domino is her
powers mostly won a probability she can
bring herself what you would call good
luck and good luck to others within a
small field around her and give bad luck
to those outside of that field so she's
standing next to all these people on the
plane here say they jump off into a
firefight as long as they stay close
enough to her she can make it so that
it's really unlikely that they ever get
hit by bullets and that they land safely
because x-force does not have a ton of
characters like it's a big team but it's
not like really really big what they
might wind up doing is is they'll kill
off a couple of these minor characters
hopefully not Terry Crews because he's
just amazing and then they'll add
negasonic and Colossus to the actual
x-force movie team with cable but if we
got to pick and choose
here I'm gonna say they keep Terry Crews
and obviously Domino so small chance
they wind up killing off shatter star in
zeitgeist during the movie but you never
know like they haven't said anything
about what the actual x-force team is
gonna look like it just this is the
proto version of that because I think
originally before all this Disney Fox
stuff was going on the idea was is to
use Deadpool 3 is more of a jumping off
point for x-force and then those movies
would come within relatively close
proximity to each other because they're
still working on x-force right now there
are people that are writing that movie
but they're also sort of making the
Deadpool 3 script back-to-back so
there's a lot of stuff that's happening
in this Deadpool universe simultaneously
behind the scenes and I think that's
just so they can keep things moving on
in a relatively normal schedule but we
also have that Deadpool TV series so
that will basically bridge any gap
between Deadpool movies but talking
about Julianne Denison's character and
the villain because everyone's like
who's the villain of Deadpool - are they
really gonna do black Tom Cassidy
there's a rumor that they're doing him
I'll talk about him in a second Julian
Dennison I'm still thinking is gonna be
the butter ball character just because
of his ability to start fires but the
thing about that is that he's actually
an Avengers character so they might have
done some character swapping with Marvel
but remember when they made the original
Deadpool movie
negasonic powers were a little bit
different Fox wanted to change those so
they had to horse-trade with Marvel a
little bit that's actually a funny thing
if Fox has control of all these x-men
based characters they can do whatever
they want to with them except change the
way that their powers work they actually
have to go to Marvel to get approval for
that Marvel is not obligated to give
that to them so there's always a little
horse trading that goes down but
obviously if all this Disney buyout
stuff goes through that's not going to
matter anymore
now as for black Tom Cassidy being the
villain the only way they could actually
do him and do what it looks like they're
doing which is sort of follow up to the
first Deadpool movie in the Weapon X
program trying to create weaponize and
sell mutants on the black market black
Tom Cassidy doesn't really get involved
with a lot of that kind of stuff in the
comics now he does go after Deadpool but
that's mostly to get his healing factor
he wants to steal his powers he is a
really deep cut deadpool villain and he
does wind up turning into something of a
talking plant so they could make all
kinds of Groot jokes if they actually go
that direction
it's a complete mess I'm not boring
you're boring
you know what's boring sitting there
playing that mind-numbing game what's
boring is me tripping over your bindings
every day I'm not boring so there's
still a lot of questions when it comes
to the actual villains but remember this
is all building towards an x-force team
up and what do you find in x-force comic
books typically you find much bigger
villains like you find stripe you find
the techno virus so they might be doing
a version of the techno virus there's
just a little bit different that spins
out of what's happening during this
Deadpool movie but I don't think they're
actually gonna do the straight-up
techno virus from the comics so if
you're not a big x-force comic book
reader don't worry too much about it in
terms of mythology think about the way
that the Logan movie dealt with a lot of
the Weapon X offshoot stuff that was
happening in the near future inside this
building they are working on something
new something they think is better than
the children something they say is
without us basically trying to grow and
weaponize mutants so I think even though
Logan kind of existed by itself in
continuity cable comes back in time to
stop terrible things from happening so
that's what he's back here to do to save
these mutants from being taken in by
whoever the villain is Josh Brolin was
actually making some jokes about getting
back in shape for the reshoots that
they're getting ready to do for Deadpool
because they're still working everyday
on that movie that's what the actor that
plays Colossus said that you don't see a
lot of him during the trailer because
there's still a lot of work left to be
done on the film but Josh Brolin posted
this funny video and it looks like the
trainer that's helping him get back in
shape for cable stuff which is this
whole area like this is the most insane
workout that you've ever seen now you
know some of the secrets of Ryan
Reynolds sick sick ABS so let me know in
the comments do you actually think that
they call the surviving members of this
team of x-force by the end of Deadpool 2
or do you think that they completely
save that for Deadpool 3 which is like a
full two years away and they haven't
really said anything about starting
production on x-force so that's still
sort of blowing in the wind I think even
if the Disney Fox deal goes
that stuff will still get made but
there'll be all kinds of Deadpool
dropping in the next couple of months so
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos I am doing a Marvel giveaway
because the Black Panther is coming out
right now then obviously we have
infinity war stuff happening
it's an Infinity Gauntlet replica all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and share the video using
those tools on the watch page and make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts because the Olympics is happening
right now so it's gonna get really crazy
and there will be a bunch of stuff
dropping so we'll talk about all kinds
of infinity war stuff next week
especially with black panther coming out
but click here to rewatch the Deadpool
trailer again and click here for brand
new infinity war thank you so much for
watching maximum effort I'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]